hello there you're watching the press
preview of first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive
and in the next half hour we'll see
what's making the headlines with rachel
cameron deputy online editor at the new
statesman
and also peter obaughn author of the
assault on truth and columnist
at byline times thank you so much for
joining us peter your first trip to sky
newspaper so
special thank you to you this evening
let's take a look and see what is on
the front of some of those papers and
the metro leads on the vaccine milestone
more than 15 million reasons to be
cheerful
is the headline the guardian reports
that downing street is resisting
pressure from tory mps to end the
lockdown by may
the times says ministers are looking at
ways of allowing people to go on
self-catering holidays over the easter
break
while the mirror says the prime minister
will soon reveal an exit strategy to
ease
some of the restrictions it's baby joy
for the duke and duchess of sussex on
the front
page of the sun as the royal couple
announced a new addition to the family
and that photo also makes the daily star
splash
whilst the ft reports on rifts in the us
republican party after donald trump was
acquitted
in his second impeachment trial
well let's now speak to rachel uh conor
and peter obama thanks again both of you
rachel we're going to start with you
and obviously the story we've been
leading with tonight and it is on a
front of most of the papers tomorrow
that this 15 million
target of vaccines into arms has been
reached good news
it is so nice to be able to start a
press preview with some good news
yes 15 million people have been
vaccinated that means that they have
received at least their first jab um and
that the government also also announced
that it has reached its target
uh beat its target in fact of
vaccinating everyone
in the first four vulnerable groups so
that's people
over the age of um
over the ages of 70 in in care home
settings in medical settings
and with underlying conditions and that
the aim was to beat that to get that
done
by the 15th of february obviously today
valentine's day the 14th
they've announced they've done it um
some wonderful news particularly
wonderful views because i remember when
the vaccine rollout first started
there were a lot of criticisms of the
government for not using
gp surgeries and pharmacies as
effectively as they could
not offering vaccinations out of hours
or
extended hours and at weekends and we
were looking at the beginning numbers
and thinking
will they be able to reach this target
because every day they're not
vaccinating enough people
but it has really ramped up and it is a
logistical
triumph that we've got to this point and
um yeah very good news
uh and peter i mean it is obviously good
news but for those who
who've had it uh and it and it does
leave
the path open to some kind of easing
from the lockdown but but
it's an arbitrary figure in a sense
isn't it that the government
set its own target and it has met its
own target should we be very very
pleased
it's absolutely phenomenal and i do
think we ought to give credit where it's
due i'm sure you know both and all of us
have criticized the government heavily
over its handling
of particularly the ppp ppe and this has
been a huge triumph and the
one person really deserves the credit
because she got
absolutely hammered in the press for
cronies and all sorts of accusations
misogynistic attacks right across the
press and at westminster that is
a lady many people won't have heard of
kate bingham remember that name head of
the vaccinations
task force worked in the city hugely
attacked
did this brilliantly made huge decisions
which of saving
tens of thousands of lives kate bingham
was a
was accused of all sorts of awful things
by a lot of journalists
and a lot of politicians a big thank you
and a big apology tonight
please to kate bingham well you've said
her name enough times
rachel it was a gamble wasn't it and we
we
yeah we we've reflected that in in the
news at 10 tonight that that it was a
big punt that the government took
on a large number of vaccines that
weren't untested and that gamble
that gavel paid off well um
you had matt hancock a few days ago
saying that he watched the
uh film about pandemics and it gave him
the idea that actually what you really
need to do is
is get as many vaccines as possible and
um make sure that you
you get your orders in in early and if
you look at what's happened happening in
in other countries and particularly in
the eu
that does seem to have paid off the
thing about vaccines
is that it doesn't really matter how
expensive they they are
they are the only way out of this crisis
this crisis is horrendously expensive
economically in terms of life in terms
of mental health so anything that you
can do
that gives you a shot out of it
ultimately ends up being worth it
and on the point about whether it's an
arbitrary figure or not
um 15 million yes it's a nice round
number that is a that's a somewhat of an
arbitrary figure but in terms of the the
top four groups
are getting vaccinated those are the
groups that account for
88 of deaths and the the
the next five groups on the priority
vaccine list which are the ones that the
government
hopes to be able to have finished
vaccinating by the end of april
altogether they account for 99 of deaths
so it's not just about numbers it's
about making sure that the people who
are
most at risk of dying but also the ones
who are most likely to put
end up in in intensive care and
therefore put immense pressure on the
nhs
they are the ones who are getting
protected and so that that
really really does make a difference it
does doesn't appear
and you know there is this this
milestone that the government has passed
but because of
for that milestone so many families now
know that the grandparents those who who
are sick
have been vaccinated and and it's those
personal stories and the
personal relationships that that are so
important here isn't it
it's not just the personal stories of
course they're wonderful but also i
think
it does show give a route back to the
nation returning to normal i mean i
everybody sort of says behind the scenes
at westminster that things are going
they deliberately done played
expectations
at the center of government so we really
are looking forward
to maybe coming out of this terribly
dark and terrible
period maybe a little earlier than we've
been
reflecting on it up to now there is a
warning
there are going to be new mutant
vaccines will these vaccines be able to
cope with those there will probably have
to be a new wave of vaccinations
next autumn but nevertheless this is
something
to celebrate yeah the guardian uh it's
from
its headline is that number 10 resists
tory demands for an end to the lockdown
by may
and that that really is going to be the
next thing isn't it rachel that we all
we all want to know now when are the
schools going to go back are they going
to go back at the end of that first week
in march
uh what kind of easter can we have with
with people that we haven't been able to
see
well the priority has to be getting
children back into schools
because that is by far the most damaging
impact of the lockdown restrictions
partly on their education because online
learning is not nearly as effective
as classroom learning and also on their
parents on on working parents who
have been trying to balance full-time
jobs with with home schooling and so
that absolutely has to be
the the priority and i think it is good
that politicians of
all parties are putting pressure on the
government there to have schools open
again
in terms of when the rest of them can
can ease
the tory hardliners are putting pressure
on the government
to ease all legal restrictions get rid
of all legal restrictions
by the end of april which as i said is
when the government aims to have those
first nine priority groups vaccinated
who are accountable
accountable for 99 of deaths now the
government has pushed back very strongly
against that
uh and obviously it easing everything
all at once we
we've learned from experience things
need to be slow and they can be gradual
so that you can
measure them but i do think that the the
tory hardliners
have a point here which is it was
wonderful to celebrate the vaccine
roller and we should
and and we are and that's wonderful but
the end goal of that
is that we can go back to some semblance
of normality
resume our lives see our loved ones who
we haven't been able to see
most of the year people can start their
businesses again
and just have to stop living under what
is effectively
virtual house arrest and if the
government says we have this wonderful
vaccine program
but they are refusing to say when it
will be when it will be no longer
illegal to have a cup of tea in somebody
else's kitchen
then you are going to get people rightly
questioning well what's the point of
the vaccine rollout then so some kind of
plan some acknowledgement
that down is it cannot be indefinite
that these are exceptional restrictions
for exceptional times
and that when those times improve the
restrictions
obviously in turn should ease i think
that is very necessary for that pressure
to be kept up
the problem is peter isn't it isn't it
if we move on to the telegraph which is
which is
its headline under the pictures of harry
and megan are that we should be able to
meet grandchildren outdoors in march
that the government
wants to obviously open up the country
economically
for schools and everything and for
people's mental health it's it's the
important thing to do
but they don't want to be in a position
where they have to re-impose
any restrictions do you think they've
done enough to ensure that
that we are safe after restrictions are
lifted
i don't know the answer to that question
i i think these are
i do have sympathy with the government
making
decisions like this at the moment
balancing
the risk that the disease will uh come
back
and as it has in the past they made
premature decisions as we know
last year um or
or or letting everything loose
personally i feel a sense
maybe of optimism perhaps that you know
that in the spring late spring maybe
life will start to return to normal
very largely due to the vaccines but uh
um
and also the return of sun but i don't
want to
criticize or second-guess the
government's decisions yeah i think
we're all feeling a bit more optimistic
as the weather gets a little bit warmer
thank you both so much we'll be coming
back after the break after
the break we're going to be talking
about the duke and duchess of sussex's
pregnancy announcement being compared to
the final scene
of a film on the front of one of the
page papers find out which
after the break
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with you now the deputy online
editor at the new statesman rachel
kunliff and the journalist
and author peter oborne and this evening
it was announced
that harry and megan are having another
baby so it is
obviously exceptionally great news for
the tabloids they love a
royal baby story we have a look at some
of the of the ways that they've looked
at the sun
has gone with this black and white image
which is the image that the couple have
released themselves
harry and meg baby number two
we can also look at the star their take
on it
publicity shy woman tells 7.67 billion
people i'm pregnant
and we've got the mail as well
interesting to see how they've covered
it given that
megan has been involved in a court case
against them but they've just played a
very straight
bat uh magnificent baby number two for
harry
and megan um rachel uh interesting to
to see the takes on this uh generally a
warm reception it's nice news
isn't it on valentine's day it's nice to
have some good news to report both on
jabs and on babies
yeah something positive for a change um
it's been a good couple of days for the
duchess of sussex
i was doing a paper review on thursday
night which is obviously the day that it
was announced that she's
won her her court case against the the
mail he published extracts of her
private letter to her her father uh and
that she she won that without having to
actually go to trial and and and now
this baby news and i
i imagine that there are some people who
are going to say as is at the point of a
daily star
um hang on you you wanted privacy but
now you
you've announced it to the world um
which you know
there is there is something in that uh
but i know quite a lot of couples who
have announced their own baby news
on social media or on facebook or
twitter and uh none of them would would
be happy about
their private letters to you to friends
and family getting getting published in
in the tabloids
so i think that announcing that you're
pregnant is kind of the thing that
i i i don't think that that suggests
that you no longer want privacy and i
think it's great news
well it is eighth and line to the throne
as well so there is a certain amount of
public interest in
a new baby on that front and peter what
did you make of the of the daily star
front page did you think it was a bit
mean spirited or
what do you think all right well they
were making quite a good point actually
was
publicity of us uh uh
what's her name megan is um you know oh
suddenly
i thought the son actually outplayed the
the
the star i played the sun the sun was
sort of a really perfect lack of
attitude in its headline the least they
could have done is something like
megazi's preggers you know a bit of fun
instead of which we uh have it like um
they're reporting you know the
changing of the guard or you know the
announcement you know
something very formal i i think that
good for the daily star
i say well done the start they've put a
picture as well
um uh at the top there the movie um
notting hill isn't it that they've used
the image from it there are similarities
between these these two images aren't
there
actually that's i'm you you've spotted
something i'm completely
missed yes dead right that's that is
that's the final scene of notting hills
you know
yeah yeah well there you go and that was
an american and an englishman as well
yeah are you very comparable to hugh
grant or maybe he is i don't know well
you just don't know i mean rachel
this child will be the first member of
the royal family there's an american
citizen
in a very long time uh as we spoke to
alistair bruce earlier he said you know
this child
could grow up to become president
uh yeah it could in in in some
fantastical universe grow up to be
both monarch of the uk possibly if a lot
of people abdicate
uh and present to the united states and
maybe could bring the colonies back to
the uk and and uh
re reunite that particular special
relationship that would be quite fun
um i love the notting hill reference i i
love the film
um and it's a perfect valentine's day
film and the star has
been doing an epic run of covers
recently they have really got
the art of the comic tabloid cover down
uh but i i do think that
again mocking them for that when um
she spoke very emotively and very
candidly about having a miscarriage
earlier in the year is
perhaps not in the best taste okay uh
lovely to see you both it's delightful
news it's just that there is the sun is
making the star is making a serious
point
well indeed well listen lots more of
this when we come back to you in half an
hour's time but thank you both very much
for taking us through your choices
at half time thanks a lot